hello everyone I hope everybody's doing
fine better than me I had a little
problem yesterday something happened to
my eye I was just walking down the
street in a bug if you're right in the
center of the eye and that left me blind
for about a minute until I scraped the
bug off of there and I was working with
uh cement after that and a bit of it
fell on the ground and just splattered
in the same eye and so if you see me
crying or see my that my eye is red then
you'll know why I've just been cleaning
my eye out with a little bit of water
and salt and that's cleaned it up a
little bit and so just so you know
anyways today I want to talk about the
neutron and good place to start and the
reason for this is you know we brought
it up at the at the forum over there at
the Facebook forum that we have rational
science and a good place to start is at
the beginning just like the Bible in the
beginning okay so where do we start
where is the beginning well the
beginning is what we covered in the last
two weeks approximately and as with the
golden principle the golden principle
says that physics requires an object you
can't do physics without an object I
mean you know what would there be to
study what would what would you be
observing if there were no objects
vacuum and if physics requires an object
the next step is to define what an
object is and we divide it in physics as
that which has shape the universal
property all objects have is a shape
and that's our starting point that's the
beginning yeah yeah and so what's the by
the way if you can't hear me or if the
image comes out wrong please let me know
as soon as possible in the comment
section I'm a little paranoid about that
I've had all kinds of problems in the
last couple weeks about sound especially
so if you can't hear me or my sound
comes out wrong for whatever reason let
me know anyways
neutron there's a little preamble oh I
want to say about the neutron or in
general and that's that yeah physics
requires an object and the object is
that words which has shape the problem
we run into is that in this at least I
would say at least since the 19th
century and even earlier than that
people have tried to figure out what
invisible objects serve as mediators
like for light for the atom whatever the
atom was you know whatever they imagined
it to be
electricity 19th century when they found
really was with Franklin Benjamin
Franklin he already knew a little bit
about electricity and other people as
well Gilbert and so on
you know they dealt with magnetism and
electricity Volta 18th century I think
was a starting point for that I'm not
sure if they knew about electricity
before then and and so you know you had
to figure out what invisible entities
are mediating these phenomena what is
magnetism what is electricity what is
light what is gravity all invisible and
so the visible stuff we had no problem
after a while we figured it out but the
invisible stuff how would we handle that
and some of the problems we have with
the neutron is that we're dealing with
an invisible entity an invisible object
let's create someone
problem because different people might
come up with different ideas what the
neutron might look like and that was
exactly the case in our forum in our you
know in our Facebook forum the rational
science group different people came up
with different notions of what they
thought the neutron was supposed to look
like or B and they had different
justifications for it and not everybody
agreed with me and hopefully they you
don't because what happens when you have
an invisible entity that you will never
never be able to see right is that you
you're gonna have to brainstorm and
first thing we got the right kind of
people to do this they're not the right
people because they're the smartest
people in the world or the most
intelligent it's because they have an
open mind they have an open mind and
they're willing to consider different
things that nobody else has pondered
they're not distracted by Dogma you go
to the University and they teach you
something what do they teach you they
teach you to memorize you memorize for
the test so you read from pages 40 to 50
write a report or or prepare for the
test and then you leave the school and
say thank God I got an A
that's it it's not like you really have
too much time to analyze what you read
in any real detail because you got other
courses and you know you just want to
get a degree maybe you know it's not so
much for understanding it's for I I
guess you could call it learning but not
understanding and that happened to be by
the way you know no exception when I
studied I learned a lot of stuff and I
learned a lot of stuff by rote in a
sense in other words it didn't really
sink yet it was when I had you know a
little bit of free time i sat back and I
am
some of these things that I came up with
you know the rope model and that's when
I abandon mathematical physics because I
realized that mathematical physics has
no rational physical interpretations you
know for any phenomena for any phenomena
in which an invisible entity serves as a
mediator and so now we're at the same
place we've got these people who are
willing to think outside the box and
they're willing to ponder alternatives
for whatever reason and yes what's gonna
happen is that you know if all these
people get together and they come up
with different ideas say no yeah that's
not what what I think of the neutron is
I think of it this way and this guy says
no I think of it that way and there's a
third guy here thinks of it in a
separate place still and then again they
have different justifications for why
they think that way and this is all good
it's not good because they get black
guys fighting against each other it's
good because we're brainstorming we're
brainstorming and that's only natural I
think you would think first because it's
an invisible entity and second because
this is a new theory a new propose a new
hypothesis you know in the case of light
and the atom based on the rope model we
have a rope and the torsion of that rope
is gonna be light and the two threads
that form that rope are gonna turn into
the electron and the proton that's the
proposal and not even and not everybody
even agrees on that
but you know that's that's the proposal
and so now it allows you to think in
different ways especially with respect
to gravity now we can have we can
understand or we can make sense of
action at a distance why does this atom
affect that one because they're
interconnected they're connected by a
rope an elongated mediator and that part
lots of people like because finally we
can make sense of how this ball over
here affects that ball over there that
parts in generally except in general
accept but when we get down to the
nitty-gritty what does an atom
like what does a new clown look like now
we run into a little bit of problems
because again you know everybody said
well you know the way I imagine it is
different than you and yes they have all
these different proposals okay so what
are some of the proposals that have been
pitched in in the last couple days and
I'm gonna go first with a simian name it
monk monkey and first I'm going to show
what he proposed as far as what it looks
like and then I'm gonna justify it with
a description and I'm sorry I'm gonna
give up the strip and then I'm gonna
justify that description with why he
thinks that way okay so here goes a
monk's version of the neutron and these
you're not supposed to laugh at the
simplicity because you're not supposed
to look at these things as as the exact
copy of what's out there the idea is to
get the notion of what he's trying to do
here how he's trying to imagine that the
neutron the neutrons the guy in the
center there okay and he visualizes like
cross section of ropes okay and okay so
that's his version cross section of
ropes that's pretty much the way I had
look at it in fact maybe I should start
by showing my version first so that you
have something compared against here's
my Neutron okay a little more
sophisticated that's what I put up there
and that's what everybody addressed I
hope you can see that big enough maybe I
can go step by step let me make it a
little bigger so we can see step by step
here we have the atom okay and on the
outside what you're going to see are the
ropes coming into that first circle
again this is a cross-section so we're
looking at two-dimensional cross-section
of the atom the ropes come from the
outside they meet at that circle which
is going to be the electron the electron
shell or you
from balloon and inside you see that
little blue dot which really is like if
you look it up closely that's if I can
make it bigger it's a cross it's a it's
a whole bunch of threads meaning in the
center of the atom okay that's what
we're looking at there and what happens
the rope Forks out at the boundary of
the atom which is the electron shell one
thread goes around and the other one
goes straight and that is a subsidy atom
so what is the neutron using the same
model
well the noodle Neutron is what you see
next to it here let's see if we can see
it in a little more detail here the
neutron is a bunch of convergence of a
bunch of ropes so whereas the proton the
centre of the atom is a cross as a
convergence of one thread the neutron is
a convergence of ropes and you might ask
well where did we get that well I get it
from a couple places first they have all
the atoms in the universe are
interconnected as you can see there on
the right all these ropes must converge
somewhere in space in fact that we
should have convergences everywhere many
convergences of ropes around the
universe and those convergences are what
we're going to call the neutron and a
convergence there and the neutron there
is what we're saying it's gonna be just
the approximately the size of the H atom
that's gonna be the diameter of that
neutron and so and that's one reason
let's let's go with a second one let's
see if I can show it here here we have
the proton and the neutron one next to
each other okay and you say well why
does the proton and
electron in other words the atom what
does it have charge and why doesn't the
neutron which comes from neutral it's a
neutral particle it does not have charge
you know and you know that's the
difference between the proton has
charged the atom has charge because the
electron shell is pumping it's coming
back and forth doing its quantum jump
it's falling in and falling out it's
compressing and expanding and the
neutron doesn't have that same shell
around it so nutri is just the
convergence of throw of ropes and
there's nothing happening other than
it's just there and I think I showed
here again here you see hopefully that's
big enough for you to see there is
there's a red circle and that red circle
is where in the regular atom the
hydrogen atom you would see the electron
shell and the neutron doesn't have that
the neutron only has a convergence of
rope ropes and so there is no charge
because there is no that pumping action
that we see with the atom and here I'll
show it one more time
okay the electron will be falling
towards the the electron shell the
electron balloon is gonna be falling
towards the proton and then expanding
it's gonna contract expand contract
expand the atom is a little heart that
is pumping tortion ways to every atom in
the universe and and yeah under this
model the neutron would be like this and
what we're seeing there as they got a
convergence of ropes at the diameter
were the electron shell would be that's
where the neutron ends that's maybe
where the people in the labs measure up
to that point they say oh the neutron
weighs more or less so much and it has
so much mass or whatever and that
Neutron has approximately the same mass
as the hydrogen
so that's where I got it from that's my
justification for it okay let's see if I
can make it smaller again okay okay
that's my Neutron according to the model
and here we have another aspect of it
that I like I usually like to share this
together so that there is a little more
information also from where I got all
this I mean it's not like I came up one
night and say oh I think this is the way
it is now I got this from the literature
the literature says something I'm trying
to explain what they've observed in the
lab and that's another issue we have to
keep in mind at all times that perhaps
just perhaps they didn't see what they
thought they saw maybe they measured
what they didn't measure it has one
possibility that there is something
wrong and what they did and that maybe
I'm just spinning my wheels because I'm
basing my take on the neutron based on
you know what they what they've done in
the lab they tell me something I listen
and how would I explain that and if they
did in fact observe some of these
sayings by observe I mean they measured
or they they were able to infer that
this is what is happy near in this
invisible world how would I explain it
and I do have explanation that's what
these justifications are they are
justifications for why the neutron has
this configuration this physical
configuration ok so here's one of the
things that I like to show and that's
that here you have the proton on the
left and the neutron on the right and
here you can see the proton is that blue
light blue stuff in the center the red
shell going around is going to be the
electron and you can see it better now
those are the
folks coming into the atom they fork out
at the electron shell the red and again
this is just arbitrary I use the red to
show the magnetic thread that goes
around and the blue thread goes straight
to the center and forms the proton and
you can see on the right you don't you
you won't see the electron shell what
you'll see simply across such cross
convergence of ropes whereas the protons
convergence of threads here we have
convergence of ropes and since it
doesn't have that pumping action where
the electron pumps back and forth
electron shell shrinks and expands then
the the neutron is neutral it doesn't
create what is called charged charges
what happens at the boundary of the
electron shell the red shell on the left
and that's that little tiny friction
when the electron shell expands and
contracts during doing quantum shell
that's what we call charge okay and you
don't and you won't see it on the proton
become the neutron on the right because
there is no such boundaries there's no
such electron shell all the ropes simply
go through all the way to the other side
but what is the problem the problem is
that the proton and electron on the Left
every 15 minutes and us again this is
what I get from the literature okay so
don't quote me on this quote the
literature honest the literature says
that a free Neutron out in space one
that does not belong to an atom which
one which is not inside an atom right
that free Neutron can convert to an atom
H atom like on the left and the H atom
every 15 minutes can convert or does
convert into a free Neutron always
talking about hydrogen atom only so
we're saying that a atom can convert to
a neutron and does convert in a neutron
and the neutron does convert in
to a net an hm and we're talking about
free neutrons only okay now that's the
official version and I haven't I didn't
bring it here today should have done
that maybe but I show in the book how
one converts into the other and they do
so simply by unrolling one of the
threads from the center of the neutron
it unrolls backwards and forms the
electron shell and then that same
electron can do it in Reverse it can
re-roll its way or wind up all the way
to the center and convert itself into an
atom so you can go back and it can go
back and forth it can unwind and rewind
from the center out and from the from
the outer edge of where the electron
shell is inwards and that's what I think
is happening when there is a atom to
neutron conversion and neutron to atom
conversion all this is based again on
the literature that these people say
this is what we observed in the lab ok
ok so that's the story for neutron to
proton conversion and vice-versa
and the other thing I'd like to show
which also gives me an idea that or
justifies where I got a lot of this
stuff here it is and this is how a
hydrogen atom regular hydrogen atom that
has no neutrons in it suddenly expands
and incorporates in other words the I
think oh yeah there it is in the first
picture you see that the atom that's the
H atom and it's got a little Neutron
that pinkish by the purple whatever the
picture you see there that pinkish one a
little star that's next to it that's a
neutron and the atom is going to expand
the electron shell is gonna guess
and and it's going to incorporate that
little Neutron in it and it's you know
now it's gonna convert into deuterium
deuterium is a hydrogen atom that has a
neutron in it in its nucleus
so where whereas the ordinary atom only
has a proton in its center and the
electron shell under the rope model
right the deuterium would have proton
it's in a center and because the
electron shell expanded it now
incorporates a neutron that happens to
be in the region or that again it's
bombarded in there I'm sure that the Sun
must be creating a lot of deuterium's in
there you know deuterium atoms isotopes
of hydrogen because you know it just
squashes a neutron in there and from
there we work our way to the next step
which is another neutron appears in the
vicinity and that's also compressed in
there as you see in the final picture
there on the bottom left and that
deuterium has converted into tritium
tritium is one proton to neutrons it's a
heavy hydrogen and just by the way you
know they use deuterium the proton and
neutron for the h-bomb okay that's what
they use they don't use regular hydrogen
and then the whole process is also
reversible in other words a tritium atom
which is a hydrogen with two neutrons
can convert it into deuterium hydrogen
with one Neutron which can convert back
to a hydrogen a regular hydrogen which
is a prote you know hydrogen without any
Neutron or you can say that the the
nucleus only has a proton
tritium is radioactive and this more or
less explains why it says look you know
the atom the electron shell has expanded
so much I mean we're talking about a
very tiny thing but even so you put two
neutrons in there you know it's pushing
the electron shell outwards and it just
wants to get rid of a neutron because
the pressure is so high in there and so
I think that's why tritium is
radioactive it's just once you get rid
of a neutron because the electron shell
has expanded so much and so pretty amiss
very unstable and it's radioactive
that's where the unstable means
essentially that it releases stuff and
in this case it releases a neutron and
deuterium to some degree is also you
know not radioactive but it's it wants
to get rid of that extra Neutron hasn't
it doesn't like it and finally I want to
say one more thing and that's that you
know the official story is that God
created neutrons so that the quantum
atom could keep positive charges such as
protons in the nucleus separate you know
it's it serves as a barrier because it's
neutral okay so if you have I don't know
atom like calcium which is atomic number
20
that means it's got 20 protons 20
electrons this atom also has
approximately 20 neutrons as an average
remember neutrons very later you can
have more neutrons and protons and the
official story is that the neutrons are
there to keep the proton from fighting
you know protons are positive and
positive all over the place and neutron
kind of serves as a barrier because
otherwise I guess the nucleus would
explode and this kind of defeats you
know the deuterium and tritium both
defeat that argument because here you
only have one proton so why did God put
one Neutron
case of deuterium to neutrons in the
case of tritium inside these atoms
what is it separating the proton from
what is it isolating it problem and
obviously if with that argument you can
say well you know the purpose of the
neutron is not to keep charges positive
charges separately so that they don't
affect each other
no that's not the purpose of the neutron
the neutrons simply is caught in a
bigger in a greater expansion of the
electron shell I think that's the
purpose that's why God created the
neutron it just gets caught into a
bigger an expanded electron shell okay
so that is my part and now let me work
here with what other people have
suggested here we have monks picture
Agana that's what it looks like his
Neutron is also across a convergence of
ropes okay
how does he justify it or what's his
description of that here's the
description he says let's see if I can
expand it so I can read it I think give
me a second here okay he said here is a
summary of my position neutron is a
composite object okay the neutron is to
rope what matter is - hmm not sure I
understood that completely I guess the
monk will have to clarify that for us
ropes combine to form free neutrons and
are also incorporated into atoms to form
higher elements that's in C we agree on
that
therefore the neutron is a linchpin okay
what does he mean by that a thing vital
to the organization of matter in other
words I think he's gonna use it as a
mediator between atoms so to speak I
think that's what he's referring to and
it's also a pin which is inserted
between fundamental and other composite
objects to keep them in position okay
that's his
justification description of what what
he just drew there an example a neutron
is held and holds together two hydrogen
atoms to form helium keep in mind if the
monkey is correct there what is he
referring to he's saying that you need
four hydrogen atoms to form helium okay
and again please let me know if there's
some problem with the sound as soon as
possible you need four hydrogen atoms to
form helium apparently this is my take
on it the Sun squash is four hydrogen
atoms in its center and it creates
helium how by putting two protons and
two neutrons and that's why you need
four hydrogen atoms okay and there's a
release of so-called energy which is
under the rope model is simply links in
a rope that are being expelled at high
frequency and those a right to arise as
heat the conversion of hydrogen into
helium creates the heat so in this sense
we agree in in how the Sun works with
quantum mechanics they use fancy words
such as energy which nobody understands
nobody has ever defined I'm saying no
let's let's do it with objects I'm
saying what's happening here you take
four hydrogen atoms you squash them
together you create four items in the
center of the helium atom two protons
and two neutrons with that okay and in
that process of squashing them together
we release links of rope in other words
we release the slack right it's not like
we're creating rope or just it's the
same rope it's just announced it has
more slack and thats that goes off as
high frequency okay so that's my take on
it and monk apparently seems to agree
with that he likes that part he'll
correct me if
and then okay so what is his
justification he says assumption the
same amount of thread is always present
totally an agreement
we do not create matter from space or
vice versa we do not convert matter into
space so you know we can't create
nothing from something and we cannot
create something from nothing
that's essentially you will he's saying
here the amount of thread in the
universe is always the same so if the if
the thread if we could measure the
thread it's a closed loop thread there's
only one thread in the universe if we
could measure the thread using meters go
around and just measure how how long
this thread is all around which would be
all the matter in the universe and we
say okay it's a trillion miles or
trillion meters whatever it doesn't
matter
so we'll call it a trillion meters then
what we're saying is that trillion
meters is always constant okay you can
have maybe more neutrons and probe then
atoms or more atoms than neutrons if
they're converting one into the other
and not everybody agrees with that but
I'm just proposing this I'm saying that
you can have you know at any point in
time you may not be able to know if you
froze the universe how many atoms are in
the universe because you can't freeze
the universe there are a kind of
converting one into the other in in
between and so maybe today we have more
neutrons and protons than atoms and
tomorrow it's the other way around for
all we know but the point here is that
the amount of thread in the universe
that that comprises all of matter that
amount of thread is constant okay
because that follows from the fact that
a single thread comprises everything
every atom every Neutron out there okay
so all this is made out of the same
thread one thread that converts into all
these tiny objects and he continues the
ratio of atoms to ropes would
necessarily be changed if atoms
converted to ropes or ropes converted to
atoms and he goes on to justify that and
again that's essentially what he is
saying is we cannot create matter from
avoid third paragraph instead we may say
that in the case of neutrons becoming
atoms and atoms becoming neutrons we
have atoms incorporating or releasing
ropes in between atoms and atom may well
slide along its rope wording counters a
neutron okay so he's saying how does a
neutron get incorporated into an atom
well the Animus ylides and kind of bumps
into the neutron the neutrons suddenly
incorporated into that and the last
paragraph there in neutral I think
that's what he's saying by the way you
know please uh I'm trying interpret what
he's saying so I could make an error in
interpretation last paragraph a neutron
is a result of Criss crossing ropes when
enough are crossed an atom may appear to
be formed and atom is not actually being
formed in a sense of being created from
nothing right and Adam has slid to the
point where the ropes crisscross and
picks up the ropes incorporating them
into itself okay so he's saying again
that I guess this is what he's saying
he's saying that an atom slides along a
rope and as you know as it eats rope in
front it releases rope behind it kind of
like you know beat sliding along the
abacus the wire of an abacus the beat
doesn't pull the wire with it and
doesn't doesn't swallow I guess it does
swallow the the the wire in front of it
in a sense that it goes through it but
the point is that you know as it eats
wire in front it releases wire in the
back okay so the bead that slides on an
abacus doesn't stay with the same piece
of wire at all times and that's
essentially the analogy for what's
happening to the at the atom slides
along a rope and as it does so it
releases rope behind it so there's so an
atom is kind of dynamic entity in that
sense
it eats new thread and releases thread
as it moves along a given rope okay
wherever in whichever direction it moves
and so up to that point I think we have
no no disagreement with a monk I think
okay he's gonna correct me if I said
something I was supposed to okay okay we
have here Tom's in the drum I'll start
with a picture also and what he did was
correct my version of the atom and here
I'm gonna need some help because I did
not understand everything that he
proposed let's go over the first one
here and essentially he corrected
everything on the left okay where you
see that white nine all around there so
the rest is the same
or or easy didn't address it but here we
see his atom he says the atom is
different than when I'm proposing okay
and he's essentially saying that the
rope
I guess swings around I am I'm assuming
he's referring to the rope the blue and
red threads at the bottom let's see if I
praise this a little bit
he calls it mating and I am assuming
that the rope is swinging around I'm not
sure exactly everything he's referring
to there I need for him to clarify that
to me and here he shows a picture of
what he considers the proton to be again
he uses the term mating they mate maybe
here Tom had sex in mine I don't know
maybe he is sex start and that's where
he got the idea
hopefully that's it's a positive origin
for his thoughts and he says roads from
different locations
okay okay that's how he pictures it here
is his justification for it
first the description then will go with
the justification he says I don't agree
with it completely referring to my
picture
oh I'm sorry Tom I thought it was Tom
says this is marking your hopes
illustration okay so I'm mixed up a
couple guys here I thought it was Tom
it's Martin instead okay fine no problem
again the point I'm trying to make that
people were brainstorming different
ideas in okay so we'll take that this is
Martin's as I said he says I don't agree
really completely I therefore revised
okay that's no problem okay I therefore
revised your atom chart okay my revision
stems from the idea of mating ropes
forming the atom not convergence of
threats okay so he's saying that this
mating of ropes is what forms the atom I
still don't understand that completely
and I'm just gonna have to ask him to
clarify that maybe tomorrow or in our
forum over there in Facebook exactly
what he's referring to with making of
ropes the monkey also had some questions
about that so we're not understanding
he's happy what he means by mating of
ropes and please don't be shy though
don't feel that you're gonna be
embarrassed or anything like that it
doesn't matter you were brainstorming
and we're dealing with something we
can't see
so all ideas as crazy as they might be
are welcome okay everything goes here
just come with your best idea even if
you're you don't match
mother nature's idea or what she really
does out there it doesn't matter who we
need all the ideas we can get and he
said with mating of ropes we have a
physical structure holding the shape of
the atom fixed I find that fixed shape
impossible with converging threads I
think what he's saying I'll try I'll try
to put words in his mouth again he's
saying that he doesn't like the idea of
I guess the two threads forking out at
the electron shell and one thread
continuing to the center of the atom and
the protein in that case being made of a
single thread
you know a bunch of convergence of
threads it said he says the atom is a
convergence of ropes I think that's what
he's saying I cannot imagine that
because then we have to distinguish that
from the neutron and I'm not sure
exactly how he does that yet
okay and a few things make me feel that
neutrons are really just hydrogen atoms
that do something okay fine
neutrons are neutral they are neutral
typically because they don't do
something but not doing something is
also doing something so I have no
problem with that statement and what are
the things that they do they have the
same mass okay essentially they do
proton and an electron together
approximately are have the same mass as
a neutron that's what we receive from
the lab and again I would urge you not
to put your life on the line for that
okay and that's important we can only we
can only use whatever these people tell
us that they've observed in the lab we
don't deal at this level on a daily
basis we can only try to theorize
explain what these people say that they
saw in the lab or what they experienced
what they measured whatever and they're
saying that they approximately have the
same mass the neutron equal to
approximately the mass of a hydrogen
atom and we're talking again the most
popular hydrogen atom we're not talking
about deuterium or Trillium no third
thing comes close to their mass okay
fine next in line is deuterium with mass
- okay fine
neutrons magically reappear yes and I
assume he's referring to the conversion
oh yeah I think that's that's what comes
next number four they convert into each
other hydrogen - Neutron Neutron -
hydrogen and again this is what we get
from the literature don't put your life
on the line for it but it's a good
speculation or a good assumption that
maybe what they saw in the lab is
correct okay that maybe it matches what
mother nature does out there so you know
just uh treat it with a lightly that's
all I'm saying okay
okay what is uh Martin's justification
for it he says it takes four hydrogen
fused together to get one helium and I
agree there two of which convert into
neutrons okay yet the mass stays the
same yes and maybe sometimes they
disappear but they are permanently fused
together until fission or decay okay no
problem there at least from my point of
view what's the likelihood that two
things exist that are almost the same
Martin says to first paragraph yeah this
is okay I got a mixed up please don't
beat me up I kind of did I copied some
of the things that I saw in the in
Facebook forum so I could have confused
both you guys don't don't kill each
other and don't kill me okay you
probably know what you what you put out
there okay so correct me whatever when I
would use your names oh I'll try not to
use your names
I'll keep you anonymous okay so what's
the likelihood of two things that are
almost the same yet one is permanent the
others temporary okay so one of the two
says so why can't we explain neutrons
are simply being squeezed or collapsed
hydrogen balloons and I don't know if
this was also from monkey maybe maybe
maybe I'm using his word here okay the
collapse of the electron shells create
what we call a neutron okay and the
electron collapse means it will have no
charge and emit no light that's the
model that I'm proposing okay so if one
of you two guys proposed that well we're
on the same page okay as far as that's
concerned okay
and now I've got someone else maybe this
is Tom or or uh or Martin I hope I don't
confuse you oh no this is Dan
I think it's Dan let's go with Dan's and
Dan says the following he drew this
which I liked not that I agree but I
like
like this his to picture especially the
second time I'm gonna shave in a minute
and he tried i guess he's trying to show
here what i'm proposing at least as far
as you know the first two pictures up on
the top that's my idea of where i'm
saying you know the rope reaches all the
way to the electron shell there it forks
out and one turns into the proton which
is the blue that's in the center okay
so far so good we that's we're in
agreement there and then the one on the
right up on the top right okay is the
neutron is just the ropes going through
a center okay and the only thing i would
check to is that you know you see a
little curvature there i want to make
sure that those ropes are straight okay
because the rope coming from one atom
over there in in the middle of nowhere
goes right through the center and
continues going to the middle of nowhere
and any other direction in other words
all these ropes just crisscross and
they're tight so the neutron is a
perfect star in that sense a perfect
ball okay it's just and that's up to the
radius of the atom if you take that
little chunk of ball there if you could
cut the the ropes at the diameter of the
electron shell you would have a a
neutron ball and what is the neutron
ball well it's a porcupine that's rolled
over a sea urchin with all the quills
pointing in every direction that's
essentially the image that you should
have in your mind okay so now the next
one that's the on the left hand side
second picture down the one in the
middle he's opening i guess he's gonna
open that right he's saying that the
threads from the from the hide from the
neutron start pulling outwards as you
can see there and leaves the proton in
the center and that thread and we'll say
that the red thread is pulling out is
unrolling itself that's gonna create the
electron shell the red circle that you
see encapsulating the proton dandy-lion
as i call it
that's a good analogy for that as well
and the one on the left and the bottom
we go from atom to Neutron the same
thing but in Reverse and the third one
the last one the third one on the right
I guess is just the it has both in there
and I'm not sure if he's saying that I
think this is what he's saying but again
don't quote me maybe this is what the
what an atom that is higher than
hydrogen
could be deuterium there I guess that's
what he's showing you where the both the
proton and the neutron super impose upon
each other and again I don't want to
double guess him but this seems to me
okay that's what he's showing there he's
he's showing how if you want to build
deuterium you're gonna bombard that
Center with a neutron and it's gonna
superimpose with a proton and so the
single line there that you see that's
gonna be the proton dandy-lion you know
all the quills pointing every direction
and a neutron superimposing that is is
all are all these ropes that crisscross
there as well okay so I love that
picture this is pretty good at least
this conveys the idea you know that's
that's the image I have in my mind I
don't have to put them side by side the
way they're always drawn by quantum
people they put proton next to the
neutron and here he's putting them
together which is good that's new I
didn't think of it that way either but I
think it's a very good proposal and let
me go with his second picture which I
absolutely loved I'm gonna see if I can
steal it from Dan maybe he'll allow me
to steal it and and that's what he did
here he's he's showing a cross-section
of an atom in this case it's the tritium
atom I guess and he shows two neutrons
superimposed on a proton I guess proton
dandy-lion
that's I think what he's showing us as
you work your way down okay
and that's as I understood these
pictures love them thank you Dan
you're still there I think this is very
good this is good work at least to
convey doesn't have to be perfect it's
just that you need to convey the idea
you need to communicate the idea that
you have in your mind and this is good
this is good for that it could be that
the atoms pissy at the hydrogen level
the protons and the neutrons superimpose
the questions whether higher elements
more massive elements such as again
calcium or carbon or oxygen whether they
because remember the they have P
orbitals you have all these balloons
sticking out like you know clown that
does all these tricks with balloons and
puts one balloon next to the other and
you have all these balloons sticking out
well you have a round one in the center
and then you have all these P orbitals
figure eight orbitals right sticking out
of it in every direction and the
question is whether the neutrons are all
in the center in which case they are not
captured neutrons like monk and I
suggest I guess captured in the sense
that they would form the nucleus of the
p orbital it's like they all go to the
center so you have superimposed protons
and neutrons all in the center okay
and the criss-crossing or brokes in the
criss crossing of threads in the center
but then you also have the p orbitals
which are just the brown balloons and
all the protons are in the center
somehow and that's a
that's a new idea too for me at least
and I think that's what Dan is proposing
he'll correct me if I say something that
I'm not supposed to but I liked his
pictures I did I thought that was pretty
good and here's I think he had a
justification for that or no there was a
tiny debate there and we didn't get an
answer to that but monk said the
following he said ropes don't bend and I
agree with that statement and let me
tell you why
rope is pulled tight it has to in order
to send light electromagnetic waves
portions so in order for the rope to
carry out in a straight line you know to
be straight and at the same time be able
to torque light in a rectilinear path it
cannot bend and when I did my work and
looked at all this I could not discover
any situation as of today in which the
Rope can bend it's always tight and part
of it is because one is wound around the
other they're pulled tighter so they
they embrace an axis so in a sense the
thread is already curved but the rope if
you look at the robe you could say it's
a straight line but of course a rope is
is never straight in the sense the
architectural II you know it's not
straight it's already a bent object in
that sense all we're saying when we use
the word straight is that the two
threads embrace a an imaginary straight
axis that's all we're saying okay so
keep that in mind
rope pass-through rope what would keep
the neutron within the what would keep
the
within the electron shell roll
well yeah but see you've been mine
Martin yeah okay so I think what you're
saying but okay well you need to explain
maybe a little more clear yeah I'm still
not understanding exactly what you mean
by mating but let's see if I can let's
see if I can make sense of your previous
statement Roth young goes the ropes
under certain circumstances keep that in
mind
only under certain circumstances what
would keep there's a promise sound again
oh Jesus for ice you know it always
starts at the same time either towards
the end okay let's see okay let's see
I'm not sure what happened okay we'll
have to cut today and we'll continue
tomorrow I'm not sure why I'm having
these problems I'll see you tomorrow
same time same station bye bye